this week the Democrats could barely
contain themselves as they thought
they'd found their smoking gun on
impeachment I think it's very damning
and you know I think it's puts a
politically mortal peril at this
presidency devastating to Donald Trump
this is the my most disturbing day in
Congress most shocking it really is
shocking shocking devastating mortal
peril and so ridiculous these people
what got them so excited the testimony
of this guy bill Taylor our ambassador
to Ukraine who apparently claimed the
president wanted to withhold military
aid and a White House meeting unless
Ukraine's new president publicly said
he'd investigate not just 2016 election
meddling but the Biden's to Taylor's
claim is also in his published witness
statements so what's the truth well we
don't know all of it because this whole
thing is still being run in secret the
Republicans calling out the secrecy has
led to a new talking point for the
Democrats and Trump hating media the
facts are bad for the president so all
they can do is attack the process that
is nonsense and here's why with facts
one there was nothing new in bill
Taylor's testimony essentially he just
embellished what we heard weeks ago when
a bunch of text messages were leaked to
when Taylor was questioned about his
quid pro quo claim his story fell apart
he is Republican John Ratcliffe what the
Democrats wanted to believe was that
ambassador Taylor's testimony would
support what the whistleblower said when
in fact his testimony established the
opposite three bill Taylor's story was
also contradicted by another diplomat
closely involved in all of this kurt
volker the volca was interviewed by the
impeachment committee weeks ago but you
didn't hear the Democrats and the ruling
class state media jumping up and down
about that why because as we told you
weeks ago his evidence exonerated
President Trump on the main impeachment
charges
looks like the Democrats love for those
career diplomats they've fallen over
only extends as far as the ones who want
to get President Trump so no this was
not the smoking gun or anything close
bill Taylor is a bust he claims he's not
political or biased and says he's worked
for Republicans
and Democrats that's not the point this
is about populist versus establishment
insider versus outsider not Republican
versus Democrat this is the system
striking back of course Bill Taylor it's
political of course he's biased just
like all these career civil servants
coming out of the woodwork they want
power without accountability and the
very people who lecture us about
democracy in the rule of law put these
bureaucrats on a pedestal instead of
exposing them for what they are arrogant
stuck-up Nowell's
trying to take down a president who's
challenging the system and its power and
finally if Bill Taylor is such a fine
upstanding unbiased servant of the
people why the hell didn't he call on
Ukraine to investigate the Biden's Joe
Biden boasted about controlling aid to
Ukraine six hours the prosecutors not
fired but as we keep telling you the
real scandal is not the firing of the
prosecutor it's cash for gas billions of
dollars of US taxpayer cash controlled
by Joe Biden going to Ukrainian energy
interests including burr yzma where his
son was on the board how much taxpayer
money did Joe Biden give to a Biden
family business why didn't bill Taylor
want to look into that oh because along
with Biden he's part of the
establishment and this is how they roll
and by the way all these Democrats
pompously pontificating that it damages
our national security to hold up Ukraine
military aid you know who did that first
your precious President Obama he refused
to arm the Ukrainians against Russia at
all it was President Trump who did this
whole part as an impeachment fast is the
biggest crock of you-know-what since the
last one they put out there which
consumed this country for three years
and proved to be nothing we know what
this is about
they hate Trump they hate you for voting
for him in 2016 and they're terrified
you'll reelect him in 2020 because Trump
has got the economy booming
delivered his promises and the
candidates they've got are all useless
finally this is not just about the
president personally it's about his
policy agenda and the populist movement
the system is striking back they're
trying to crush the populist revolution
and we have to fight to defend it please
share this by following us that Steve
Hilton X and that next rev fnc